Speaker Kevin McCarthy
spoke in the subject.
He falsely equated
former President Trump's actions
after the 2020 election
with the losing campaigns
of Hillary Clinton and Al Gore.
Take a look
at I can say the same thing
that Hillary Clinton says
about her election that she lost.
I can say the same thing about the DNC
who said it about the 2016 race.
I can say the same thing
about those in the Democratic Party
from the leadership on down
about George Bush
not winning that Al Gore did.
But were any of them prosecuted?
Were any of them put in jail?
When Hillary Clinton said it?
Nothing happened to her
when they said it in Georgia's election.
Nothing happened to them either.
You know what?
When the DNC said it
nothing happened to them. I
speak for McCarthy just a short time ago.
Here with me,
CNN political commentator
Van Jones of our Griffin Adam
Kinzinger and David Urban,
also legal analyst Ellie Hoenig.
Karen Friedman. Agnes, hello.
Congressman Kinzinger, what do you think?
My gosh, I just I can't watching that.
I can't do it.
I mean, he's he knows he knows better.
He knows that's complete garbage.
And those are all just as red
meat talking points thrown
and even even to
the base would look at that and go,
that's not the same thing.
It doesn't make an ounce of sense.
And you can see how angry he's
been getting lately, by the way,
when he speaks, Kevin.
And it's very rare
for him to get angry when he speaks.
But he's been doing it more and more.
And my guess is
this is tearing him up inside.
He's mad not at the people
who are asking the question.
He's frankly mad
that he has to come up with that lie
and stand there and say that.
And I think Marco
Rubio tweeted even yesterday,
because some actors did a video
where they were asking
the electors in 2016
to vote for Hillary Clinton
instead of Donald Trump.
And he was equating that
that's very different.
It's okay to ask electors
to switch their vote.
It's not okay to create fake electors
and attack the Capitol and get your way
if you're not even convinced.
Kevin McCarthy believes
that watching that
I mean we saw this
kind of echoed similar
talking points Elise Stefanik
put out a strongly worded statement
they're using all the same terminology
we'd expect
witch hunt
this is to distract from Hunter Biden.
This has absolutely nothing
to do with Hunter Biden.
They were all there in the Capitol.
I'm old enough to remember
when Kevin McCarthy said
and we have audio of him saying,
I am done with this guy
talking about Donald Trump.
He bears responsibility for this day.
But now that's just out the window.
I mean, I don't know
how Republican supporters
of someone like McCarthy
see those two things and kind of like
put them together
because it's just a direct contradiction
and it's
so shallow and yet, David Urban,
I mean, this is repeated
time and time again.
So the RNC,
I mean, I know Congressman
Kinzinger is losing his mind over here,
but I think, you know, a lot of this is
you know,
I was going to say
to the average American,
you know, distinction
without a difference.
And these in these previous videos,
if you watched the Martin Sheen video,
that kind of the 100 celebrities
kind of plead the
you know, having faithless electors
Electoral College
or if you watch
the RNC as a video out,
which I saw on social media
about a half hour of you know from 2016
on that period of saying
you know
Trump is not a legitimate president.
We need to resist.
You know all the resistance movement
and all those things and
and you know contesting his presidency
from that from the outset.
You know
the articles in the Washington Post
saying Trump needs to be impeached today
right. And on and on and on.
That's what's going to be said.
I'm not saying it's correct.
I'm saying that's
what's being said to Americans
and this
I know that the
our legal experts, you know,
think this is a well-crafted
legal document. I'm sure it is.
But to most Americans, it's white noise,
which is why you agree
that the most Americans
don't remember that
the Capitol was formed and that
false electors
don't agree on the January six part.
I don't disagree with you,
but I think
that there's a disconnect here.
This is not a January six indictment.
If you read it.
This is
this is about a fake elector scheme.
This is not about storming the Capitol.
Here's the problem is it is, Wolf.
Now, it's like it is
it's not what they're going to throw
it is the issue, not just the speech.
It's the fact that they've charged over
they're going to punish on Kinzinger.
Congressman Kinzinger
said he'd like to see
a subsequent indictment.
Yeah, I would say they're going to throw
tons of garbage out there.
The point isn't
that it's not going to confuse people.
It is. That's all strategy.
And the problem is.
Hold on. Let me finish.
The problem is leaders
like Kevin McCarthy
have to be
the ones to go out people
and show the difference
and tell the truth.
We are letting leaders off the hook
because we're like, oh, well,
you know, it's like, no,
don't be in leadership of your unwilling
to say
the hard truth to people
in terms of the legal battle ahead.
Obviously,
the judge would like a speedy trial.
The government would like a speedy trial.
The judge was also
used to be a defense lawyer.
So looks after the rights
of the defendants as well.
How speedy a trial can
there be and exactly who decides that?
So the judge said
you have a week to tell me, Mr.
Prosecutor,
how much time
you think this trial will take.
And then the defense has a week
after that to tell them.
And she's going to take that information
and use that to build a trial date.
Now, I know one of the defense attorneys,
John Laura, has been saying
this trial
could take nine months to a year.
But let's think about it for a minute.
The prosecution has the burden of proof.
The prosecution is the whole show.
They put the whole trial on.
The defendant doesn't have to do a thing.
They don't have to open.
They don't have to cross-examine
a witness
they don't even have to put on a defense
at all.
So really, the question for a judge
is how much time government
is your case going to take?
And that's really the critical part.
And then you ask the defense,
what defense are you going to put on?
It seems very unlikely
they would put on the former president.
Exactly. And are they?
Let's say
Jack Smith says this is a six
or eight week trial,
which I think that's
probably right around what he will say,
what the defense attorney
is going to say.
So I have another six months
worth of evidence
that I'm going to put on.
What is he going to put on?
And so at a certain point, that argument,
the judge will push back on that
and say, let's be realistic.
You don't have to commit to
what exactly what you're going to do.
But if you were to put on a defense,
how much time do you think it would be?
And I think the judge can
do a fairly educated
guess of how much time this would take
and how long it would be.
Same thing with the pretrial motions.
We all know we could.
Ellie and I could sit here right now
and tell you what
the pretrial motions would be.
It's obvious
what the arguments are going to be.
You know, First Amendment,
free speech, you know, advice of counsel
is another one.
I want a change of venue, you know,
because I can't get a fair trial. Here.
I want you judge, you're recused
because you're biased.
And you said the thing about
presidents aren't kings.
And, you know,
he'll make so many different arguments
that that are just very obvious.
And the judge will give him enough time
to make those arguments.
As you know,
you could do that
in two months, for example.
And the government
could probably respond
in another two months.
Jackson
is going to give over all the discovery.
There's no reason
this case can't go in January,
February,
and be done
before the first vote is cast.
Even even in early voting,
the judge's role
at a trial is sort of like a ringmaster.
You're trying to wrangle
aggressive, opinionated parties
that have not just their own agendas,
but competing agendas.
And one of the challenges for a judge is
how do you keep control of your trial
I've had judges
who cannot control their courtroom
and let defense lawyers
or maybe sometimes prosecutors
run roughshod. And it's a nightmare.
I've had other judges
who have been strict, strict
but fair and said,
we're going to get this done
in X amount of time.
I'm going to give you one week.
I'm going to give you two weeks.
I'm going to give you 2 hours
to give you a closing argument,
not 8 hours.
And so a lot is going to lie
on the hands of Judge Chuck Ken.
And by all indications,
she is a firm, tough in control.
Judge, I've talked to people
who've appeared in front of her
you can see it in her ruling.
She is a no nonsense, no bias judge.
And so I think she's going to
and she knows we're all watching.
And so I look for her
to push the pace here then.
Yeah, I'm I'm still reflecting on the
my colleagues here
and then
and the passion of the over there.
And this is going to require us
to get through
this next
18 months, is going to require us
doing something
that we're just not
that good at as a country,
which is nuance.
It is in fact true.
There were progress of
working to delegitimize Trump
from the very beginning.
It is true.
And they were not prosecuted.
That is true.
And there were conservatives
working to de-legitimize Obama
from the beginning,
including Donald Trump,
who said he didn't
have a birth certificate
and they weren't prosecuted either.
It turns out there's a lot of speech
that's not prosecuted.
But what you won't be able to show
is a Democratic president
sitting in the Oval Office
trying to hold on to power
in the way that Donald Trump did
or frankly,
or Republican president
any president
in the history of the country.
And that's the truth.
And so the problem is to your point,
Adam, there's going to be a lot of stuff
thrown out there
to your online, on social media, etc.
And we're going to sit here
and look at it.
You know, two things can be true.
Yes.
A lot of horrible stuff
was said about Donald Trump
before he had a shot.
Some of it turned out to be,
frankly, quite correct.
Also, a lot of horrible
stuff is being said about Joe Biden
right now. Nobody's going to jail for it.
There is one person
being charged in this country
and as the one person who's done
something that no president has ever done
as Donald Trump.
And here's
a quick question of the lawyers here.
So how much discovery
is too much discovery?
Right, because that's what I hear
from the Trump folks, right?
It's like this is great for us.
Now we get to open the Pandora's
box of election fraud
and America will see what
we've been saying. The whole time.
Right.
That's what you've seen and you've heard.
And I suspect that if the judge disallows
extensive discovery
that the Republicans will say, aha, see,
there it is.
They're not allowing us to show America
what's really going on.
So how much is too much discovery
is everything to to put it in one word.
As a prosecutor,
you have to turn over essentially
everything you have to the defendant
but I think the question you're
raising is a really good one.
How much leeway will the judge
give the defense in going?
Let's say the defense says, Judge,
we want to prove that the election
was stolen in some of these seven states.
Will the judge allow them to go down
that road,
which would vastly expand this trial?
They could say,
we want to go to
each of these seven states
and we look at election exactly right.
And it's within the judge's
purview to say,
no, I find that's not a valid defense.
I find you've not given me
at least a nugget of information
that I can work with. So big ruling.